- tell chairman Adam Schiff now calling
for an independent commission to
investigate the federal government's
response to the Cova 19 pandemic the
congressman tweeting after Pearl Harbor
9/11 we looked at what went wrong to
learn from our mistakes once we
recovered we need a nonpartisan
Commission to review our response and
how we can be better prepared for the
next pandemic I'm working on a bill to
do that joining us now to react ranking
member of the House Judiciary Committee
congressman Doug Collins often by Adam
shifts side but maybe not on the same
side congressman is this the time to
bring up a commission no it's not and I
think there's gonna be enough the with
the packages that we just passed of aid
that is going to people starting in the
next few weeks we have oversight in that
we have Specter General's there's stuff
that's been put in there to make sure
and look at a certain point in time
there will be a look back at this
there'll be a little back that what
happened and how it came about but also
I think it's gonna be actually to look
back here that I'm not sure Adam Schiff
wants to talk about and that is China's
role in this and the fact that as
Intelligence Committee Chairman he was
so wrapped up in impeachment during when
all this hit that I'm not sure that
there was a slow response on both sides
because no one was looking at this
because he was so focused on the
president and what he was trying to do
in an election that we were missing
basically China's role and others I mean
we seen this before I'm not sure he
would like the the outcome of this
report any more than he did any other
reports that he had this past year
absolutely and the rise of al-qaida was
really muted by the fact that President
Clinton was so caught up in his own
impeachment I hope we start learning
from this meanwhile on the cause and the
terms of impeachment Adam Schiff was
asked did you word Pietschmann inquiry
hurt the president be able to look after
the potential pandemic here's his
response Mitch McConnell said that he
believes that the impeachment trial in
the Senate slowed down the federal
government's response yeah the president
said something similar which you know
was an interesting acknowledgement that
the administration has screwed up this
response and I think the facts are quite
clear that the president's weeks long
maybe months long delay and taking this
seriously has had catastrophic
consequences
what's your response to that Brian he
just can't help himself this is a man
who for a year is nothing nothing but
over a year's attack this president
tried to go through the mower for the
impeachment he said there was things and
you know the president did you know it's
in plain sight that he did wrongdoing
it's just can't help himself even in
corn - even in isolation it sounds like
all he wants to do is focus on the
president's not the president of a good
job as he is focused on this we have all
learned from this crisis of going and
the president has been listening to his
advisers and moving forward but there
can be no mistake that in the month of
January in December when Adam Schiff was
leading this country down a sham
impeachment that there was a distraction
on Capitol Hill you saw it on both sides
of the aisle that they were so focused
on this you know for him to come back at
this point and try to you know regain
the spotlight from his failed attempts
of impeachment it's just sad for the
American people we need to be focusing
on what's happening now getting the
drugs that you just talked about with
dr. oz getting these folks the money
that they need so that our economy can
recover as we go through this and being
taking care of the people who are losing
family members and losing lives and
losing businesses right now again this
is so premature but it's not frankly
it's not nothing new for Adam Schiff and
the thing is congressman Collins
Anthony foutch II was on the Katz
roundtable syndicated radio show January
26 saying I don't think that virus from
what they know is going to be a big
problem here so the best in the business
who basically pushed and pushed America
towards a cure for AIDS was caught by
surprise to a degree about the degree of
this how do you expect the President and
civilians to pick up the magnitude of
what we're experienced there's one
people group of people to blame it's the
Chinese government who still it's not
telling us the truth this is one time in
which we don't have to be Democrats and
Republicans we can be Americans and
again we're back to the same old divide
I wish people would start growing up I
agree with you completely I think I
think the president was very diplomatic
yesterday when he said those numbers
were like come out of China listen I
think for most of us we can agree
Republican and Democrat that the numbers
were wrong and I think when dr. Falchi
statement and others it just shows that
they were not being a forthright in the
outcoming of this their reports and what
they were seeing and now it's time for
us to come together acknowledge that and
then movement we're taking care of the
people who need the the help of each
other as Americans we always pull
together we're in this together and we
got to continue this fight right now and
good luck with your Senate run I know
it's getting very hard with remote but
everyone's dealing with the same thing
congressman thanks so much